las razones principales que argumentan
los republicanos es que Omar había hecho
comentarios antisemitas durante su
estadía como congresista en la comisión
de asuntos internacionales de la cámara
de representantes y por eso dicen los
republicanos es necesario sacarla de
este comité porque no representa los
intereses de Estados Unidos sin embargo
lo que argumentan los demócratas es que
pues son más los republicanos los que
hacen comentarios antisemitas en redes
sociales y abiertamente y frente a eso
no hay repercusión y no han sacado a
ningún republicano que haga parte de
esta comisión como si lo hacen con
hildan Omar entonces pues los demócratas
están diciendo que esto es más un ataque
a una mujer de color inmigrante que
llegó con su esfuerzo al congreso y que
han calificado los demócratas esto como
no solamente un ataque de venganza
porque en los últimos años cuando los
demócratas estuvieron liderando la
cámara de representantes pues ellos al
mando de la cámara de representantes
sacaron de sus comités respectivos a
Marjorie Tyler Green y Apolo por pues
comentarios racistas y radicales y
también antisemitas recordemos que estos
congresistas
pues han hecho abiertamente comentarios
también y temitas antisemitas pero no
han tenido repercusión de parte de los
republicanos Así que no solamente los
demócratas están diciendo que esto es
una un ataque una venganza por haber
sacado previamente a otros republicanos
de sus comités cuando los demócratas
tenían la mayoría sino que también es un
ataque a una mujer de color inmigrante
en el congreso Cristóbal Omar no ha sido
la única demócrata que ha sido expulsada
de los comités de la cámara que otros
congresistas han vivido una situación
similar Y a qué se debe
Sí de hecho hoy también el presidente de
la cámara de representantes Kevin
mccarthy que es muy cercano a Donald
Trump pues anunció la decisión de sacar
del comité de inteligencia de la cámara
de representantes a Erick southwell y
también a Adam shift ellos hacían parte
no solamente de este comité sino también
de Pues a todo el esfuerzo que durante
la mayoría los últimos dos años cuando
los demócratas tuvieron mayoría en la
cámara de representantes pues estos
congresistas llevaron a cabo una ardua
investigación en contra de Donald Trump
y obviamente para tratar de esclarecer
lo que pasó el 6 de enero del 2021
cuando Pues simpatizante de Donald Trump
Se tomaron el Capitolio la decisión de
Ilan Omar pasó por plenaria de la cámara
de representantes en total fueron
218 republicanos que votaron para
sacarla 211 demócratas que votaron para
que ella se mantuviera a su cargo pero
pues en esta decisión contra otros dos
congresistas demócratas del comité de
inteligencia pues era decisión
unilateral y tenía ese poder el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes precisamente para
sacarlos del comité de inteligencia
donde pues ya no van a tener el acceso a
la información confidencial que tenían
cuando lo estaban y cuando avanzaban en
sus investigaciones en contra del
expresidente donal